former president Donald Trump has
pleaded not guilty to 34 felony counts
related to allegations he falsified
business records in connection with hush
money payments Joe takapina is one of
the attorneys on Trump's legal team and
he joins us now Mr takapina I'm just
going to jump right in at its most basic
level it looks like what the district
attorney has done here is is charge your
client with essentially creating a
public relations plan that took bad
stories and found a way to get rid of
them and instead of paying for that plan
with his own money he's falsely claimed
it as a business expense president
former president Trump says there was no
crime is your defense that there was no
crime at all or that he just wasn't
involved in this scheme
there's no crime at all um at all uh you
know it's it's not exactly accurate to
say he claimed as a business expense he
did not there was no tax deduction taken
here I mean I'm seeing a lot of stuff
out there you know this indictment was
very vanilla I mean it did not list the
underlying crimes he's allegedly
intended to cover up with those false
business records because the D.A felony
so
the VA says they're not after what
it doesn't have to list the crimes that
that's not required by law no no among
those he listed he said taxes were one
of the crimes but
normally it doesn't have to list the
crimes but normally it does okay you
don't have my law to list the Crimson
indictment but what's the height why
wouldn't they bring them forward we want
to get some strategic Advantage I mean
this is not a game you're charging the
president of the United States with
crimes crimes that will never be
sustained under court of law because
they don't exist there are no tax
deductions taken here there were no
filies with the FEC feces come out and
said there's been no violation of FEC
laws so I don't know what crimes we're
talking about exactly John but is
falsifying business records just as a
matter of course is not a legal thing to
do and you're saying there is no
business records of any kind whether
it's taxes or otherwise nothing was
falsified ever at all
not only is nothing falsified but
nothing was filed so I could have my own
Ledger in my checkbook I pull out my
pocket and write uh I'm buying a horse
instead of buying a car in my ledger
whatever maybe I don't want my secretary
to see that right but unless I file that
with an authority like the tax agencies
or I'm taking the tax deduction or if
I'm running for office I have to follow
with the FEC for some reason there is no
crime I could write whatever I want my
personal Ledger there was no filing
obligation he never filed anything that
would invoke a false business record
claim which is a misdemeanor by the way
you'll have to work that out with the
D.A who says there was a tax violation
uh let me ask you about the former Trump
organization CFO Alan weisselberg he is
throughout the statement of facts here
he is uh he's currently
um serving because he uh was convicted
on 15 felonies including falsifying
business records he's uh he's obviously
somebody who can corroborate the claims
of the D.A will he appear do you think
as a win Fitness for the prosecution or
the defense
in no scenario he appears a witness of
the prosecution I mean if you listen to
his trial testimony he oh but exonerated
Donald Trump in any knowledge of
anything he pled guilty to committing
his own personal tax crimes
um and that's a whole different case
with a whole different set of facts and
a whole different set of scenarios that
happened there that quite frankly to me
were unfair where this guy was pressured
the 70-something-year-old guy was
pressured to go forth and take pleas on
minuscule things that would never been
prosecuted except for the fact that he
was Donald Trump's CFO but his his so in
this case you have his handwriting on
materials that are in furtherance of
this deception uh you say it has nothing
to do with taxes it may also have to do
with with uh campaign Finance violations
but I mean his word doesn't you know
necessarily it doesn't necessarily need
to testify because they've got documents
showing him in furtherance of this
scheme so he's not exactly helpful in
that regard yeah
no he's exactly helpful to our client in
that regard because there was no scheme
and there was no crime let me try and
break this down very simply there's two
key elements here was campaign money
used or was personal funds used first of
all was personal funds there was no
campaign money used because it wasn't a
campaign issue this was done to prevent
an unpleasant story
let me finish my answer let me finish my
answer he'll get to that so the second
part is simply this
when you have personal funds used during
a campaign the rule of law is for
campaign Finance is was that expenditure
made that payment made solely for the
purpose of the campaign because if it
was made irrespective of the campaign
then it's not a campaign Finance
violation clearly here even Michael
Cohen when he pled guilty said this was
done in part to prevent embarrassment
for the president and his family that
takes it out of the realm of FEC
campaign Finance law violations that's
why the justice department is in charge
of them that's why the FEC didn't charge
him
um so you have to understand the law
here the the campaign Finance law and
this is a first a state prosecutor is
bringing a violation of federal election
laws never happened in this country
before
final question to you about your client
former president Trump says I have a
trump-hating judge with a trump-hating
wife and family
does that help the case
it doesn't help the case didn't hurt the
case as a statement of fact a statement
of fact based on the daily mails
reporting and others reporting that the
judge's family members work for Miller
Harris
it's a trump-hating judge so the health
the case
it's a fact that it's a trump-hating
judge
it's a fact it's an opinion of someone
who's been put through a political
persecution John it's not a fact it's an
opinion of someone who has the right to
feel aggrieved he was in a you know this
was the same judge from the last round
of the Trump organization trial so there
were some issues there a recusable
motion was made there so it's his
opinion but you you know you act like
this is a normal day he's been put
through something that no one else if he
was not Donald Trump he would not be a
defendant no one else would have been
prosecuted in this country for this
crime because it's not a crime it's a
campaign you know Hillary Clinton who
actually said legal fees for a Steele
dossier which was dirt digging got a
fine from the FEC he gets indicted for
using personal funds 30 other people
have been indicted on this falsifying
charge by this D.A but I understand you
say that this that's not what's happened
it has to be tied to a a violation of
federal election campaign laws it is not
my guess is we're unlikely to work this
out now but Joe I appreciate you going a
few rounds with me